quarante ans de ma vie à traquer les
criminels et tout à coup plus rien on
aperçoit d'état pendant que l'étape en
taule urbaine auriculaire avec vous
connaissez pas la police s'occupe tout
ça c'est plus fort que moi
franck sidekick interpol et vous vous
êtes le castor berry cas pas de limite
d'âge dans la presse française
la liste vient d'un groupe qui
kidnappent des surfeurs à travers le
monde tout cas cet extrait de t-shirts à
l'issue du sommet
pourquoi je compare à ce penalty canard
trêve pascale une gueule à faire des
conneries août et douze semaines
franck j'étais jour là où ils vont pas
traité ne l'inquiète pas la leur ce truc
qui m'a fait tenir la c30 venant se
lâche on va attraper ces mecs je vais
retrouver ma place comme ça crame
vikings
surtout la cuisson est capable de faire
je vends réponses concrètes
tu te rends compte que tu les auras 109e
est important c'est qu'ils puissent
chercher ses jours
le cancer peut commencer